barack and michelle it's my honor to
invite you both to the stage for the
unveiling of your official portraits
come on
okay
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much thank you everybody
thank you
thank you
thank you so much
please everybody have a seat
have a seat
thank you
thank you
thank you sit down everybody
thank you very much
[Applause]
it is great to be back
president and dr biden
vice president harris and second
gentleman emhoff
thank you so much for your hospitality
thanks for letting us invite a few
friends to the white house
we will try not to tear up the place
[Laughter]
someone
someone once said that
if you're looking for a friend in
washington get a dog
our family was lucky enough to have two
wonderful dogs
but i was even luckier to have a chance
to spend eight years
working day and night with a man who
became a true partner and a true friend
joe it is now america's good fortune to
have you as president
you've guided us
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
you have guided us through some perilous
times
you've built on
and gone beyond
the work we all did together
to expand health care to fight climate
change
to advance social justice
and to promote economic fairness
thanks to your decency and thanks to
your strength
maybe most of all thanks to your faith
in our democracy and the american people
the country's better off than when you
took office and we should all be deeply
grateful for that so thank you so much
[Applause]
to all the former obama biden staffers
who are here in person some of you are
watching at home thank you for being a
part of this
when people ask me what i miss most
about the white house years
it is not air force one that i talk
about
although i miss air force one
it's the chance that i had to stand
shoulder to shoulder with all of you
to have a chance to witness so many
talented selfless
idealistic
good people
working tirelessly every day
to make the world better
and for eight years
and
even longer for some of you
i drew on your energy and your
dedication
and your goodness
you inspired me
and i never wanted to disappoint you
and i tried to reflect the same heart
and character
that you displayed every day
even during the toughest times it was
all of you that kept me going
so it's good to be back to have a chance
to see all of you and to once again say
thank you
now
as much as i miss our work together
what's been a special joy is to see
what's happened since
because
so many of you are doing amazing things
whether it's in government in the
private sector
in academia or non-profits
and i'm especially glad to see so many
of you serving president biden
as well as you served me
although uh now some of you who let's
face it your kids back then are now
in charge and running the show
which
is a little shocking
and may also explain some of the gray
hairs i'm seeing on some of you
but it validates what i had always hoped
which was that our time together would
only be the beginning of incredibly
impactful careers
and some of you
who i've had a chance to stay in touch
with
i'm thrilled to see that
you've started families of your own
i am a little disappointed that i
haven't heard
of anyone naming a kid barack yet
or michelle
but there is still time
finally i want to say a special thanks
to the white house staff
we had a chance to
see them all beforehand
[Applause]
you took incredible care of our family
for eight years
and along the way you became a part of
it
and
uh we have not ever forgotten uh the
kindness that you showed us
now
when michelle and i had our portraits
unveiled at the national portrait
gallery a few years back
i said that as far as i could tell no
one in my family tree had ever sat for a
portrait before
i certainly had not
and now all of a sudden we've done it
twice
but these portraits have a special
significance
because
as joe mentioned they will hang
in the white house alongside portraits
of other presidents and first ladies
dating back to george and martha
so
it was important to find the right
people to paint them
i want to thank
sharon sprung for capturing everything i
love
about michelle
her grace
her intelligence
and the fact that she's fine
[Applause]
she is
her portrait is stunning
and i want to thank robert mccurdy for
taking on a much more difficult subject
and doing a fantastic job with mine
robert is known for his paintings of
public figures tony morrison the dalai
lama nelson mandela muhammad ali
but what i love about robert's work is
that he paints people exactly the way
they are
for better or
worse he captures every wrinkle on your
face
every crease in your shirt
you'll note that he refused to hide
any of my gray hairs
refused my request to make my ears
smaller
he also talked me out of wearing a tan
suit by the way
[Applause]
his work is so precise that at first
glance it looks like a photograph
and robert also paints his subjects
looking straight ahead
so it feels like you're face to face
forming a connection
and that appealed to me
in part because
presidents
so often get airbrushed
even take on a mythical status
especially after you've gone and people
forget all the stuff they didn't like
about you uh
but what you realize when you're sitting
behind that desk
and what i want people to remember
about michelle and me is that presidents
and first ladies
are human beings like everyone else we
have our gifts we have our flaws
you've all experienced mine
we have good days and bad days
we feel the same joy and sadness
frustration and hope and while it takes
a certain amount of self-confidence to
be president
there are nights where we lie awake
wondering if this or that decision was
the right one
i've always described the presidency as
a relay race
you take the baton from someone you run
your leg as hard and as well as you can
and then you hand it off to someone else
knowing that
your work
will be incomplete
the portraits hanging in the white house
chronicle the runners in that race
each of us
tasked with trying to bring the country
we love closer to its highest
aspirations
and when future generations walk these
halls and look up at these portraits
i hope they get
a better
honest sense of who michelle and i were
and i hope they leave with a deeper
understanding that if we could make it
here
maybe they can too
they can do remarkable things too
now
it is my pleasure to introduce someone
who needs no introduction
michelle was the best thing about living
in the white house and let me tell you
uh
the patriot chefs here deliver delicious
pies on request
so that is saying something
um
i could not ask for a better life
partner
and in my humble opinion america could
not have asked for a better first lady
please give it up for michelle obama
well just to explain to you what we've
been watching those of you who've joined
us in the last quarter of an hour it is
a ceremony that should have taken place
four or five years ago under president
trump it's an official unveiling of the
presidential portraits of the former
president and the former first lady who
you can see was just about to talk there
michelle obama we've just heard from
former president obama and uh i suppose
the breaking news that came out of it
was that uh after the introduction by
the current president joe biden was that
they like each other very much it
turned into something of a democrat
loving well of course it would but as i
say the significance of it is that it
illustrates
the deep enmity and it is that that
former president trump holds for the
democrats and in particular barack obama
in that he uh would not allow that
ceremony to take place so here we are
it's
six years of course since president
obama was in the white house as
president joe biden was his vice
president's uh the role's kind of
reversed of course
no
formal office for former president obama
but uh joe biden they're very fulsome in
his praise for barack obama and also
promising to uphold the principles that
he and president obama upheld while they
were both together in the white house